[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an indian survival
drama film called trapped
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
sharia is a call center employee living
in mumbai india he has had a crush on
his co-worker nuri for a long time
one day he gathers enough courage to
call her but is too shy to express his
feelings but starting that day he calls
her daily and engages in an awkward
conversation that nuri seems to enjoy
she loves to flirt with shorya and make
him nervous but is annoyed at the fact
that he never asks her out when he calls
her the next time she asks him to guess
her favorite food in 5 seconds if he
guesses right she will go out with him
but if he is wrong she will stop picking
up his calls although nervous shorya
guesses correctly and lands a date with
her that evening they go to a street
vendor to eat her favorite food sometime
later they are in a restaurant talking
about different things when nuri
casually mentions that she is getting
married in two months a surprised shorya
asks her if her marriage has been
arranged by her parents when she
confirms this he continues the
conversation ignoring the topic
that day marks the beginning of their
friendship nuri starts to look forward
to meeting him and hardly pays attention
to work they go on several dates and
start falling in love with each other
one day shorya brings her to his
apartment that he shares with three of
his roommates they lock themselves in
his room and start making out nuri stops
abruptly and is visibly upset thinking
about her future shorya asks her to
cancel the wedding and elope with him at
first she thinks he is joking but starts
to consider it when he insists when she
says that she cannot live with his
roommate he promises to find a new
apartment by tomorrow and move in with
her her wedding is in only two days so
they will have to be quick right after
she leaves shorya calls several dealers
to look for an appropriate apartment
however because of the timing and low
budget he cannot find one he spends the
entire day visiting apartment complexes
with little to no progress during one of
such meetings a stranger overhears him
talking about wanting an affordable
place he approaches shorya saying that
he has a perfect place for him shorya is
skeptical at first but he agrees to come
have a look at the apartment anyway he
is brought to a newly built high-rise
apartment complex that seems to be way
more expensive than what he can afford
he is told that the complex was built
two years ago but is empty due to
construction and legal issues the
apartment that he is being offered
belongs to a man who hardly ever comes
to the place the stranger he just met is
only a caretaker of the place but since
the owner has been absent for two years
he is unethically handing it to shorya
for money the couple will be the only
people living in the massive building
which unsettles shorya but when he gets
a look at the apartment he forgets about
all the sketchy things related to it it
is massive with a bedroom a kitchen a
living area a bathroom and a fenced
balcony the place is clearly worth way
more than the price he is paying he
finalizes the deal and gets the keys to
the place following that he packs up his
luggage from his old place but doesn't
tell his roommates about his plans to
elope he simply claims that he is going
home for a few days and leaves
anyone that's had roommates before knows
that this is a dick move
at his new apartment he lays down a
mattress cleans the room a little and
falls asleep hoping to surprise newry
the next day he has put his phone on a
charger but the power cuts off the
following morning he wakes up late and
quickly does his morning routine he
further notices that none of the taps
are working and has to use bottled water
to brush his teeth after a few minutes
he finally steps out of the apartment
and locks it however he has to run
inside again to get his phone he forgets
to get the keys and accidentally locks
himself inside nuri calls him and asks
him why he is late shorya explains that
he will be there in a few minutes but
doesn't tell her where he is to keep it
a surprise
wow at this point shorya deserves to be
trapped when the call ends and he tries
to get out he realizes that he is in
trouble he forcefully tries to open the
lock but fails he finds some tools in
the drawers and uses them but without
the keys opening it seems almost
impossible following that he calls a
helpline asking them to send someone to
break the lock but to his misfortune his
phone dies before he can tell them the
address he tries to charge it again but
the power outage only makes it more
difficult shorya gets more irritated
with time and starts to bang on the door
to break it but is unsuccessful yet
again moreover he hurts his hand in the
process
moments later he comes to the balcony
and calls the watchman who cannot hear
him because of the traffic and the
height sharia finally registers that he
is stuck in the apartment his plan to
elope with nuri has failed because she
will probably think he has run away
afraid of commitment he cleans the wound
with the little bottled water he has
left in hopes of charging his phone's
battery he keeps it out in the sun but
it does nothing following that he
continues shouting for help hours pass
but no one hears him at night he eats a
packet of biscuits and falls asleep when
he wakes up the following morning the
power is still out and the taps aren't
working either he yet again tries to
open the door with everything he has in
the house even after throwing a chair
and a fan at it it doesn't budge shorya
is now ready to take extreme measures to
get out he unplugs the tv mounted on the
wall and throws it off the balcony it
lands below with a loud bang but the
watchman still doesn't notice it later
he eats away all the biscuits and is
left with little to no water he notices
several pieces of cardboard on top of
the kitchen shelf and thinks of a plan
using his toothpaste he writes help and
the name of the building on them and
drops it off the balcony to his dismay
the cardboard lands on someone's roof
where no one is going to find it shorya
is useless but he doesn't lose hope and
does the same with another piece of
cardboard that lands on another
building's roof when he runs out of
toothpaste he uses his blood to write
the message and drops two more
cardboards off the balcony one of them
lands directly below the building while
the other one lands on someone's terrace
he stays on the balcony waiting for
someone to find them and look for him in
the evening a woman comes to the terrace
to pick up clothes that had been drying
in the sun shorya gets up and starts
yelling at her but is disappointed when
she doesn't notice the cardboard at
night he goes to the kitchen and sees
that he is completely out of food he
also notices a rat on the floor and is
terrified while trying to run away from
it he hits his head on the wall and
falls unconscious shorya now officially
has my vote for the darwin award the
next morning he wakes up still on the
floor he sees that the tap in the
kitchen sink is working but he is too
scared to go inside because of the rat
soon it runs out of water and he is left
disappointed he had broken his glasses
last night so he fixes them with a
pajama string in another attempt to make
someone see him he builds a makeshift
slingshot and uses it to launch pebbles
at the woman on the top of the roof the
pebbles catch her attention but she
ignores them after seeing no one around
another day passes in a similar way at
night shorya uses his clothes to write
help on the balcony's bar and starts
banging the bars with a pan he does it
until the morning but no one hears him
the watchman finally finds the cardboard
he had thrown but the guy cannot read so
he ignores it later the woman from the
nearby house also finds her cardboard
she looks around but cannot see shorya
from that height he yells for help
trying to get her attention and is
overjoyed when he sees her coming to the
apartment complex the woman asks the
watchmen if anyone stays there the man
claims that he has worked there for two
years and is positive no one is in the
building the woman is still not
satisfied so she goes up several floors
however the empty place spooks her so
she returns home shorya sees her leaving
and loses the last speck of hope he had
when it turns dark he burns the clothes
that were hung on the bars when that
starts to blow out he also lights the
mattress on fire he jumps up and down
sure that the fire is bound to get
someone's attention however the plan
goes wrong when the fire spreads to a
couch he somehow blows it out with his
vest and falls asleep out of hunger he
dreams of eating his favorite meal with
nuri like they used to he also remembers
the survival shows that teach you to eat
anything once you become deserted taking
the advice he goes to the kitchen to
kill the rat but freaks out when it runs
towards him the next day thirst gets the
better of him so he reluctantly pees
into a pan and drinks it however the
taste makes him vomit right after he
spends the entire day sleeping and wakes
up the next morning to heavy rainfall
shorya quickly collects water in the pan
and drinks from it he also uses
everything that is a container to
collect as much water as he can
including the fridge the flesh tank and
the paint cans the next morning a pigeon
lands on the balcony with his only
chance shorya uses the slingshot to kill
it and use it as food however when he
tries to skin it he is disgusted a
flashback shows us the time he and nuri
were out on a date shorya who has been a
vegetarian his entire life argues that
killing helpless animals for food is
unethical back in the present he
reluctantly cuts the bird's head off and
roasts it he also gets over his fear of
rats and manages to trap it when the
isolation gets the best of him he talks
to the rat about all the ways he can
escape he has seen that an apartment
some floors below him doesn't have bars
on the balcony if he manages to get to
the apartment and the door is open he
could walk right out of it however for
that he has to cut the bars off of his
balcony first the only tool he has is a
metal sheet but he starts sawing it
anyway
several days pass but he doesn't give up
trying to cut it he feeds on ants
cockroaches and occasional birds when
things get tough he starts to miss the
little things he used to dread like
getting pushed by sweaty people on the
bus weird fetish but okay after many
days of sawing and burning the railing
it finally breaks shorya takes the
chance and carefully climbs down the
bars of three floors when he finally
gets to the one with no bars his legs
are too short to climb in he uses his
belt for support and finally gets inside
with much courage he pulls the door to
the apartment and is overjoyed when it
happens to be open he climbs down the
stairs and finally makes eye contact
with the watchman he has a hundred
things he wants to say to him but he
simply walks away a week later nuri
comes to visit him in the hospital she
believed that he had abandoned her and
has already gotten married he tries to
hold her hand but she moves it knowing
that they cannot be together now some
days later shorya returns to work but is
shattered to see that his friends and
colleagues had not even noticed his
absence later that day he goes to his
favorite restaurant and enjoys his
favorite food that he missed dearly in
the final scene he returns to the
apartment and looks at the broken bar
the moral of this story is
ah
i give up
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching